[Musik]
zielstrebig jungen feministin fremd sie
könne als deutschlands jüngste frau im
aufsichtsrat eines dax konzerns und das
ganz ohne frauenquote so oft wurde sie
in interviews schier ungläubig danach
gefragt bist du bis 35 aufgenommen und
der aufsichtsrat der freenet ag nicht
wie wie ist das passiert
wie ist es passiert die haben einfach
angerufen solche fragen ob sie heute
überhaupt nicht mehr hören die
emanzipation der frau müsste doch längst
in den köpfen der menschen verankert
sein sagt sie und fordert dass die
vorstandsbesetzung in deutschland
deutlich weiblicher sein müsste aber
eben auch die die quote im mittleren
management an frauen in
führungspositionen muss deutlich
erweitert werden und wenn das nicht
passiert dann sieht ziemlich düster aus
lange vor instagram gründete sie eine
erfolgreiche social media agentur könne
bewegt sich in der schnelllebigen welt
des digitalen sie kennt die trends und
fordert diversity als zielvorgabe bei
managergehältern notfalls auch mit einer
quote wie jetzt im bundestag diskutiert
das ist genau die richtige zeit für die
quote weil sich natürlicherweise aus
einem impuls heraus nichts getan hat und
wir nicht auf darauf warten können dass
das männer die gerade an der spitze sind
erkennen und fühlen dass es jetzt die
richtige zeit wird ist die frauenquote
tatsächlich die lösung in österreich
gilt seit vier jahren eine verbindliche
quote von 30 prozent für börsennotierte
unternehmen
brigitte ederer brauchte sie nicht sie
wechselte vor jahren von der politik in
die vorstandsetage über viele jahre
eigentlich sehr sehr skeptisch gegenüber
kunden um nicht zu sagen dagegen
ich muss jetzt sagen je älter ich werde
desto mehr bin ich der meinung
offensichtlich geht es nicht anders
weil wenn man sich das in deutschland
sitzt anschaut bis dato war ein argument
das man findet ja keine qualifizierten
frauen jetzt gibt es sozusagen die
diskussion oder schon den beschluss dass
es eine
eine quote im vorstand geben sollte
plötzlich finden sich frau im
siemens-konzern verantwortete brigitte
ederer knapp 400.000 mitarbeiter innen
für sie ist klar die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit eines konzerns
funktioniert besser wenn sich
festgefahrene männliche hierarchie
strukturen endlich auflösen das allein
reiche aber nicht die regierung sei auch
in der pflicht über immer der festen
überzeugung gemischte teams sind das
richtige wir hatten eigentlich eine
relativ gute entwicklung männer und
frauen bis 35 und dann sind uns einfach
die frauen weggebrochen im gegensatz zu
den jüngeren männern also das war so
dass ich habe das immer darauf
zurückgeführt dass das auch mit einer
nicht gut guten kinderbetreuungs
einrichtungen in den jeweiligen ländern
zu tun hat ich glaube dass es in vielen
unternehmen vorbilder geben muss für
genau diese vereinbarkeit von karriere
und kind und diese diese vorbildfunktion
müssen jungen frauen nachwachsenden
talente neben gezeigt werden dass es
funktioniert und es funktioniert wenn
man es auch einfordert man muss es auch
fordern und man muss dinge verhandeln
und diese diese verhandlung spielt eine
extrem große rolle
[Musik]
eine verlässliche kinderbetreuung sei
unabdingbar gerade in corona zeiten
mahnt katarina barley
sie stellt deutschland ein schlechtes
führungszeugnis aus was das angeht und
noch mehr um ein jahrhundert der frau zu
werden muss sich viel in den köpfen
verändern es reicht nicht nur dass man
verhältnisse verändert dass man mehr
frauen hier einbringt oder
betreuungsmöglichkeiten verbessert das
ist alles gut und richtig und wichtig
aber damit sich wirklich fundamental und
auch langfristig etwas ändert muss sich
etwas in den köpfen ändern wir müssen
auf jeden fall bei den jungen menschen
ansetzen
niemand wird als frauenhasser geboren
oder als anti feminist wir müssen gerade
die junge generation auch dafür
begeistern die soll diese offenheit zu
zeigen
gerechtigkeit und gleichstellung seien
die grundpfeiler der eu so war jetzt sei
es an der zeit diese auch umzusetzen
es gibt menschen die haben immer noch
dieses weltbild das männer eben mehr die
macher sind und rationaler sind und
frauen emotionaler und so weiter
manchmal passiert unterschwellig etwas
was man nicht unterschätzen sollte zum
beispiel der faktor stimme für frauen
haben meistens eine höhere frequenz als
männer
und dass das hat eine auswirkungen die
kann man messen also wir müssen generell
dazu kommen dass man nicht nach
oberflächlichkeiten und äußerlichkeiten
urteil übrigens künftig müssen nach dem
willen der eu-kommission unternehmen mit
mehr als 250 mitarbeiter innen die
gehälter offenlegen
noch ein kleiner schritt in die richtige
richtung weg von gender pay gap
für brigitte ederer kommt diese
entwicklung jetzt zu spät
im laufe einer karriere und wenn sie so
spannende berufstätigkeit war wie meine
natürlich gibt es verletzungen und damit
nahmen die hoffentlich alle verhält sind
ein preis den ich persönlich gezahlt
habe ich habe keine kinder
es macht mir weniger dass ich keine
kinder hätten wir gerne enkelkinder
also wenn wir in dem tempo weiter machen
wie bisher dauert ja noch 100 jahre wir
die die an nährende gleichberechtigung
haben und das ist mir zu lang also ich
will nicht dass meine töchter mich
irgendwann fragen warum sie nicht in
führungspositionen kommen und immer an
diese gläserne decke stoßen die
diskussion müssen sich ändern und es
muss alles viel viel schneller gehen
ein appell der sich an alle richtet
quote hin oder her
[Musik]